my name is anchormen I'm a PhD and I
work at the Lumina at the enterprise
informatics Department where we create
software to analyze genomics data like
whole genome sequencing but also other
types of data so when I was in high
school I was thinking about what I
wanted to study and I was generally
attracted to science but I wasn't sure
what I liked most and my father got sick
he got cancer and I really got
fascinated by how molecular biology and
manipulating DNA allowed you to
basically not only understand but even
treat diseases at Stanford I got really
excited about the research that I was
doing there which is looking at the DNA
of healthy people extremely healthy
people so a lot of people obviously look
at sick people try to find the mechanism
of disease try to figure out what goes
wrong when you get cancer or heart
disease would be much better if we can
actually prevent disease and we're
actually doing that already with
cardiovascular disease we're giving
people with nothing wrong with them but
a high cholesterol levels drugs to lower
cholesterol so what really motivated me
and fascinated me was taking that beyond
cardiovascular into other areas and
tried to figure out if there's anything
we can do to prevent disease what can we
find that's different about healthy
people versus sick people and that's
what really fascinates it motivates me
you